[Music]
i want you to imagine this for a moment
two men rahul and rajiv living in the
same neighborhood
from the same educational background
similar occupation and they both turn up
at their local accident emergency
complaining of acute chest pain
raul is offered a cardiac procedure
but rajiv is sent home
what might explain the difference in the
experience of these two nearly identical
men
rajiv suffers from a mental illness
the difference in the quality of medical
care received by people with mental
illness is one of the reasons why they
live shorter lives than people without
mental illness even in the best resource
countries in the world this
life expectancy gap is as much as 20
years
in the developing countries the world
this gap is even larger
but of course mental illnesses can kill
in more direct ways as well
the most obvious example is suicide
it might surprise some of you here as it
did me when i discovered that suicide is
at the top of the list of the leading
causes of death in young people in all
countries of the world including the
poorest countries of the world
but beyond the impact of a health
condition on life expectancy we're also
concerned about the quality of life
lived
now in order for us to examine the
overall impact of a health condition
both on life expectancy as well as on
the quality of life lived we need to use
a metric called the dally which stands
for a disability adjusted life here
now when we do that we discover some
startling things about mental illness
from a global perspective
we discover that for example mental
illnesses are amongst the leading causes
of disability around the world
depression for example is a third
leading cause of disability alongside
conditions such as
diarrhea and pneumonia in children
when you put all the mental illnesses
together they account for roughly 15
percent of the total global burden of
disease
indeed
mental illnesses are also very damaging
to people's lives
but beyond
just the burden of disease let us
consider the absolute numbers
the world health organization estimates
that there are nearly four to five
hundred million people
living on our tiny planet who are
affected by a mental illness now some of
you here look a bit astonished by that
number
but consider for a moment the incredible
diversity of mental illnesses from
autism and intellectual disability in
childhood
through to depression anxiety substance
misuse and psychosis and adulthood all
the way through to dementia and old age
and i'm pretty sure
that each and every one of us present
here today can think of at least one
person at least one person
who is affected by mental illness in our
most intimate social networks
i see some nodding heads there
but beyond the staggering numbers
what's truly important from a global
health point of view what's truly
worrying from a global health point of
view is that the vast majority of these
affected individuals do not receive the
care that we know can transform their
lives and remember we do have robust
evidence that a range of interventions
medicines psychological interventions
and social interventions can make a vast
difference and yet
even in the best resource countries for
example here in europe roughly 50
percent of affected people don't receive
these interventions in the sorts of
countries i work in
that so-called treatment gap approaches
an astonishing 90 percent
it isn't surprising then that if you
should speak to anyone affected by
mental illness the chances are
that you will hear stories of hidden
suffering
shame and discrimination in nearly every
sector of their lives
but perhaps most heartbreaking of all
are the stories
of the abuse of even the most basic
human rights such as the young woman
shown in this image here that are played
out every day
sadly
even in the very institutions that were
built to care for people with mental
illnesses the mental hospitals
it's this injustice that has really
driven my mission to try and do a little
bit to transform the lives of people
affected by mental illness and a
particularly critical action that i
focused on is to bridge the gulf
between the knowledge we have that can
transform lives the knowledge of
effective treatments and how we actually
use that knowledge in the everyday world
and an especially important challenge
that i've had to face is the great
shortage of mental health professionals
such as psychiatrists and psychologists
particularly in the developing world
now i train in medicine in india
and after that i chose psychiatry as my
specialty much to the dismay of my
mother and all my family members who
kind of thought neurosurgery would be a
more respectable option for their
brilliant son
any case i went on i soldiered on with
psychiatry and found myself training in
britain and some of the best hospitals
in this country i was very privileged i
worked in a team of incredibly talented
compassionate but most importantly
highly trained specialized mental health
professionals
soon after my training i found myself
working first in zimbabwe and then in
india and i was confronted by an
altogether new reality
this was a reality of a world in which
there were almost no mental health
professionals at all
in zimbabwe for example there were just
about a dozen psychiatrists
most of whom lived and worked in harare
city leaving only a couple to address
the mental health care needs of nine
million people living in the countryside
in india i found the situation was not a
lot better to give you a perspective if
i had to translate the proportion of
psychiatrists in the population that one
might see in britain to india
one might expect roughly 150 000
psychiatrists in india
in reality
take a guess
the actual number is about three
thousand about two percent of that
number
it became quickly apparent to me that i
couldn't follow the sorts of mental
health care models that i had been
trained in one that relied heavily on
specialized expensive mental health
professionals to provide mental health
care in countries like india and
zimbabwe i had to think out of the box
about some other model of care
it was then that i came across these
books
and in these books i discovered the idea
of task shifting in global health
the idea is actually quite simple the
idea is when you're short of specialized
healthcare professionals
use whoever is available in the
community
train them to provide a range of
healthcare interventions and in these
books i read inspiring examples for
example of how ordinary people had been
trained to deliver babies
diagnose and treat early pneumonia to
great effect and it struck me that if
you could train ordinary people to
deliver such complex health care
interventions then perhaps they could
also do the same with mental health care
well today
i'm very pleased to report to you
that there have been many experiments in
task shifting in mental health care
across the developing world over the
past decade and i want to share with you
the findings of three particular such
experiments all three of which focused
on depression the most common of all
mental illnesses
in rural uganda paul bolton and his
colleagues using villagers
demonstrated that they could deliver
interpersonal psychotherapy for
depression
and using a randomized control design
showed that 90 percent of the people
receiving this intervention recovered as
compared to roughly forty percent in the
comparison villages
similarly using a randomized control
trial in rural pakistan ati framan and
his colleagues showed that lady health
visitors who are community maternal
health workers in pakistan's health care
system could deliver cognitive behavior
therapy for mothers who were depressed
again showing dramatic differences in
the recovery rates roughly 75 percent of
mothers recovered as compared to about
45 in the comparison villages
and in my own trial in goa in india we
again showed that lay counsellors drawn
from local communities could be trained
to deliver psychosocial interventions
for depression anxiety leading to 70
recovery rates as compared to 50
in the comparison primary health centers
now if i had to draw together all these
different experiments and star shifting
and there have of course been many other
examples and try and identify what are
the key lessons we can learn that makes
for a successful task shifting operation
i've coined this particular acronym
sundar
what sundar stands for in hindi is
attractive
it seems to me that there are five key
lessons that i've shown on this slide
that are critically important for
effective tar shifting the first is that
we need to simplify the message that
we're using stripping away all the
jargon that medicine has invented around
itself
we need to unpack complex healthcare
interventions into smaller components
that can be more easily transferred to
less trained individuals
we need to deliver healthcare not in
large institutions but close to people's
homes and we need to deliver healthcare
using whoever is available and
affordable in our local communities
and importantly we need to reallocate
the few specialists who are available to
perform roles such as capacity building
and supervision
now for me
task shifting is an idea
with truly global significance
because even though it has arisen out of
the situation of the lack of resources
that you find in developing countries i
think it has a lot of significance for
better resource countries as well why is
that
well in part because healthcare in the
developed world the healthcare costs in
the developing world are rapidly
spiraling out of control and a huge
chunk of those costs are human resource
costs
but equally important is because
healthcare has become so incredibly
professionalized that has become very
remote and removed from local
communities
for me what's truly sundar about the
idea of tar shifting though isn't that
it simply makes health care more
accessible and affordable
but that it is also fundamentally
empowering it empowers ordinary people
to be more effective in caring for the
health of others in their community
and in doing so to become better
guardians of their own health indeed for
me tar shifting is the ultimate example
of the democratization of medical
knowledge and therefore medical power
just over 30 years ago
the nations of the world assembled in
alma atta and made this iconic
declaration well i think all of you can
guess that 12 years on we're still
nowhere near that goal
still today
armed with that knowledge that ordinary
people in the community can be trained
and with sufficient supervision and
support can deliver a range of
healthcare interventions effectively
perhaps that promise is within reach now
indeed
to implement the slogan of health for
all we will need to involve all in that
particular journey and in the case of
mental health in particular we would
need to involve people who are affected
by mental illness and their caregivers
it is for this reason that some years
ago the movement for global mental
health was founded as a sort of a
virtual platform
upon which professionals like myself and
people affected by mental illness could
stand together shoulder to shoulder and
advocate for the rights of people with
mental illness
to receive the care that we know can
transform their lives
and to live a life with
dignity and in closing
when you have a moment of peace acquired
in these very busy few days or perhaps
afterwards
spare a thought for that person you
thought about who has a mental illness
or persons that you thought about who
have mental illness
and dare to care for them thank you
[Music]